okay betches okay so we're back to this
game we're going to cut some slits up oh
I think [ __ ] okay let's stay here what's
the quest and let's get the universal k
you know it's a lot of XP and then let
you [ __ ] it let's just do better return
I get back to City Hall ok up ok yeah
this hotel
[Applause]
gosh at
ash at
how do you kick again oh it that okay I
don't know why this is like a game one
that I literally cannot remember what's
going on uh here betch oh yeah you want
to get horny with me how you want to get
horny yeah great a lot of [ __ ] here
how how oh my god by for China he
scratched my vagina I'm tired of people
scratching my vagina and only times have
been scratching the vagina the wrong way
I like we scratched in the vagina by a
real man a real man ok now let's say hey
let's see here any uh [ __ ] here that
[ __ ] is that and he [ __ ] here that
said I liked it out
that's add egg
oh what Oh Daniel like a daddy no like a
oh yeah you like that you like that much
cuz I be like hey and I guess I was like
this bad boy okay how's this thing holds
it up yeah it's almost up if I get this
is maybe I'll find something useful I
didn't find anything useful so thanks
just think positive okay that's how we
do it in a family [ __ ] we just go up to
people we just [ __ ] an attack on when
they're sleeping it's easy it was up for
singing injured I can't tell are they
like dying
it looks like they're getting injured
why doesn't say like uh yeah
good God gun that's a pretty
they're just explode oh yeah you like
that [ __ ] oh hey take this thank you I
always liked Pichai got there Kelly oh
great what is that oh that's not think
it's a mound ok he's at the mission I
can't tell
is that it find an exit City Hall get
back to city huh
[ __ ]
so now i can get out say ya gonna have
to upgrade gonna have to upgrade ok and
have so much money
[Applause]
ok
[ __ ] there's a lot going on here
the [ __ ] is going on here she's scared
it
and this looks kind of like to help
hi I'd like to close this door okay okay
how you like that him up give me that
money I deserved that what is that I
gonna hate am i that I know
holy [ __ ]
yeah shocking that's okay
God God gun a lot of people did not make
it oh I will admit that right now it
wasn't a good successful turn out there
were casualties shut all right I guess I
got in with the machete [ __ ] there's so
much noise I can't tell what's going on
oh wait now [ __ ] okay
I guess we're just done it oh great [ __ ]
she says how this was a [ __ ] out
ok
yeah they're here can I just jump down
it
I [ __ ] gone over there ok I take that
snack make that snack snack a pass na
snacky does
like that
set get on ya
sure close this door now law got in nice
[ __ ] so like what happens
they know how to get out of here
and I level up I guess
don't get it let's hack and get more
bullets
I knew that
does it have to be like shouting at
thoughts
all right how's you stump down there
yeah they don't let me jump down okay I
guy [ __ ] [ __ ]
cut this guy up I got this guy up good
good good this guys getting up now and
cut this guy and this guy's still trying
to get up okay Shay closes its not noisy
and this place really gotta [ __ ] I gotta
tell ya how this is the mayor's office
uh I guess we can get that K as well
right Chet
hey uh I got the anaweir so que o
diamonds I'll shut it's nice I can't see
fri yep tell me that yeah
how's [ __ ] okay I got to go down right
when I mess
some go down the stairs these are
probably people i miss with a [ __ ]
machete oh you seek a Japanese huh
oh [ __ ]
come on bench this way come on come on
oh that's not [ __ ] hey gal that is
something we can use press my day yeah
take that [ __ ]
let's sit here I pana [ __ ] we got a lot
of mine out what is the magic wand thing
can i write this
it'll do a magic wand mod
[Music]
it is best to 40 and 168
fuckina
tailbones the faq of that
[ __ ] okay looks like this has gone well
you shoulda quest real quick escape like
yeah that yeah I like energy drinks make
everything better
[ __ ] i think it's it class updated find
a way to the slums okay okay let's say
hats say yeah
holy [ __ ] that scared the [ __ ] out of me
[ __ ] I'm running past this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
a knock on that that's a sure what the
[ __ ]
alright i guess i was gone up yeah look
I fall
oh you bet that guy fell a [ __ ]
[Applause]
cut this bad shot you know sometimes you
just kind of cut pictures up
let me get some healthier okay okay is
that
a chef bill call my phone okay let's
suck in there this [ __ ] [ __ ] i can
get heard of a [ __ ] step on them
thank you I kept up this is a fun word
zombie but he's gonna have to die and I
he's a bomb you know I'm sorry I put him
out of his torture wow it's crazy sounds
like pretty fat [ __ ]
can I other site
[ __ ] dad ad
ok
uh-oh there's no mice in here that was
scary okay thank yet again I need that
NIJ jag wretch
[ __ ] a lot of people here
I got that my name in it shut oh this is
like the exact way long before
not my death I don't okay good
let's kick it strong [ __ ] I think they
fit the first I went through the hell is
just like running belt I'm like sprinted
through the [ __ ] guys [ __ ] spawn
right there that guy here isn't there oh
this guy just like punched her my attack
Jesus ok
Oh
is that
let's line through this bachelor fly
jealous [ __ ]
[Applause]
[ __ ] a lot of people today shut out
[ __ ] around in
[ __ ] how do i get there here a lot of
[ __ ] here
I can I
yeah okay let's see I feel a lot better
with them to dodge behind me is that
broomstick no thank you cut that [ __ ]
a top [ __ ] give me that energy jank you
know I Nana you know I need a more than
anything in the world
that [ __ ]
I can lotta [ __ ] zombies
yeah where is it hey there's a lot of
[ __ ] going on here
hmm okay
as disgusting
is a thug hey hey docs
hey Tay sex energy drinks that guy track
shovel I like that smack I'll take that
thank you
yes I doubt bet I can hassle
yeah wow how can I ok ok God [ __ ] what
the hell [ __ ] I
turn to the church right yeah i'm i
guess the church has destroyed
the shells run at their hair match
church is right over that I'll need to
make a complicated you know
she'll think they snacks baby
you
I great uh yeah that's not like I say
that don't shut away dead advice thanks
for watching thank you